welcome back to unwrapped Junior Mints
they've been on the market for more than
50 years and come from quite the candy
family they were invented by the brother
of the guy who invented sugar babies and
sugar daddies and ever since these
classics remain a favorite in the
theaters and now for the first time on
television see the secret process behind
these minty treats good peanut butter
and jelly hamburgers and french fries
there are a few taste combinations that
seem made for each other
and when it comes to movie candy one
couple is picture-perfect the dark
chocolate and the creamy mint go very
well together and I think that is part
of the attraction for Junior Mints
Junior Mints have been a main attraction
of theaters for more than 50 years now
the mini mint was invented in the 1940s
when a Cambridge Massachusetts candy
maker discovered a unique way to whip up
a soft creamy mint it's it's refreshing
is the word I like hey you taste is like
a burst of chocolate and yet mint at the
same time it's great yeah well the best
part is how it like melts in your mouth
and it turns all mushy gushy and then it
goes down the back of your throat and
that they can last a long time since
he's a junior we were wondering is there
a senior mint we have never made a
senior mint except in the laboratory but
we have been thinking about the
possibility of having a senior mint over
the years Junior was actually named
after a Broadway play called Junior Miss
popular at the time the mints rolled
into theaters even though many people
take Junior Mints to the matinee very
few have ever seen how they are made so
stand by for televisions first-ever
behind-the-scenes glimpse at the making
of these mints inside this rather
ordinary looking Factory the top-secret
process of making Junior Mints is
underway
it all begins with the combination of
sugar and corn syrup the mix is then
liquefied at a high temperature and
dripped onto a giant cooling wheel the
dramatic drop in temperature helps the
candy firm up then it's whipped with
mint and other secret
radiant's to create that creamy texture
the white paste then pours into machines
so exclusive we can only show it to you
with several men blocking the most
sensitive areas from view inside this
never-before-seen Mystery Machine the
Junior Mints Center is formed millions
of the uncoated candies pop out onto a
conveyor where they cool while writing
to the panning room
no this isn't a laundromat those big
machines that look like clothes dryers
are actually tossing them in centers
while they are showered with dark
chocolate once they've gone their
chocolate coats a final glaze is added
to give them their shine despite
changing tastes the junior mint recipe
is just as it was 50 years ago people
very funny about changing the formula so
when you have something that's
successful a manufacturer is very
careful to keep the favorite formula
however what does change sometimes is
the presentation the packaging theaters
have wanted bigger boxes and so Junior
Mints now are in large size king-size
boxes and even bigger than that
no wonder theaters have requested the
king size box there are millions of
moviegoers out there looking for a
feature-length feast because you know
you don't eat all your candy in the
previews and then be stuck watch cooking
channel for more great episodes of
unwrapped
you